yeah very good yeah yeah
it's a nice toasty warm room here i know
it's boiling i like it i know it like
i've been in here for like three hours
oh my gosh
it's a rick campanelli et canada in
toronto
yeah but you you love every second of
this yeah man it's great it's really
good fun
what are the positives what are the
advantages i don't know i mean i think
what's quite fun is like trying to
change every answer yeah i mean
sometimes obviously you get a lot of the
same questions and trying to like mix
them up a bit and then sometimes you do
find yourself sort of getting into a
routine right um but yeah it's just nice
to sort of keep keep yourself on your
toes because sometimes you do get the
the odd swerve ball and you're like oh
god i'm not ready for this question yeah
and you're not much of a baseball player
no no no no no baseball isn't something
that's that big in england
um we're cricket so we're very sort of
like that no swirl of balls and cricket
or crew you could swerve balling yeah
it's called a swinging cricket okay not
a swerve ball um but yeah see i bet you
we haven't talked you haven't talked
about qriket yet we we should get to the
movie though because yeah we should tear
them down to three minutes by this time
i can't i still can't believe this is
your first uh on-screen big screen
performance you were remarkable thank
you very much uh rave reviews the
reaction's been amazing very positive
how does that make you feel as a young
actor
it's it's so rewarding um it's something
that i've really never worked harder on
anything but this film and to show that
all my hard work is paying off and that
people are enjoying the film and it's
getting positive feedback is just so
rewarding and also hotter the director
he worked so hard this film was pretty
much his baby growing up like over the
past four or five years and just to see
that it's in it's all his hard work is
paying off and he's doing well is really
really great that's brilliant
you you get to meet lucas
this young man survived the impossible
what was that like tom
i mean meeting him was just incredible i
mean the first time i met him i was
speechless because i knew what he'd gone
through
and and he's so unaffected
but
what is incredible about him is how open
he is he doesn't hold back any part of
the story
like obviously the story is very
delicate and there's a lot of delicate
subject matter and i didn't want to like
tread onto any like invaders privacy um
but he was so open and would always
answer my questions with full confidence
and
it's great for an actor to have that
source of information and emotion there
because you can just ask him anything
about your character and no one knows
the character like he does because it's
him so um just to have him there was so
useful and like
really able to just grasp lucas and like
become the character if you know what i
mean of course i do with what he was
telling you were you blown away with
what was yeah
i mean the first interview
the meeting i didn't make notes i just
stared at him like guys i just tell me a
story and i'll listen and then the
second time i was like we'll just do
that again and we literally
i made notes and stuff and we and i was
like just drawing photos of what was
going through my head and stuff and just
completely blown away by what he went
through i mean
i can't i don't know if i would have
been able to do what he did um i know
because i'm not the best of persons in a
in a crisis right
but um but yeah you never know until you
get there but he's just such a
remarkable person lastly let's chat
about uh naomi yeah your mom in the
movie
how did she take you under her wing what
was it like working with her
incredible i um i love her a bit she's
like a motherly figure to me um she's so
kind and so generous with her work i
mean she has a fate that a face is just
emotes and like gives emotions that you
can just like take in and then give
right back
and
even if she's not on camera she still
gives 100
and she taught me that
everyone on set as a team you're not
working for your own individual
performance you're working for everyone
else um which is very important because
a film is nothing without without this
without a team so um so yeah it was just
an absolute privilege and honor to work
with her man great words you're a pro
okay all right thanks man i think your
tea is ready so i'll leave the room
brilliant thank you very much
you